or somebody else um who potentially has
knife the prime minister in the front is
conservative mp andrew morrison who quit
as a trade envoy yesterday where there's
no high why did you quit
well it's been a long burn for me kay
i've been deeply unhappy for some
considerable time i suppose the straw
that broke the camel's back yesterday
was the letter written by lord macdonald
who
was the
senior civil servant at the foreign
office when i was there to the
parliamentary commissioner for standards
which i think laid bare uh the
relationship that the prime minister has
with the truth which is something we've
known for some while uh but yesterday i
think actually just made it explicit it
basically said that the prime minister
was lying correct that's what it said
okay um we've known that the prime
minister um has a loose affinity with
the truth on more than one occasion
previously so why now well it's been
long burned i suppose you could argue
that many of us perhaps should have gone
before now but changing prime minister
is a is a significant thing it's not
something we do likely
and the prime minister has achieved a
lot i think in his time time of office
which is in anticipation which is why we
supported him in the first place but to
be honest you know enough is enough
which is why i resigned yesterday in two
very senior cabinet ministers i imagine
probably decided that they had had
enough to in your opinion what has he
achieved during his tenure well i
supported him because if you recall in
2019 we had to deal with brexit it was
acting like a sheet anchor on our
politics and on our country and it
seemed to me that boris was the only
personality that could drive that
through and he has done so has he is it
fixed i think it probably is as an
ex-northern ireland minister and
chairman of the northern select
committee
and of course northern ireland is the
main sticking point in this and always
was going to say northern ireland might
say that it's not yet well north i may
well say that and i fully understand
that position but the fact is i think
for the most part brexit has been done
it's been achieved but we have to deal
with the northern ireland protocol
clearly that's unfinished business okay
did you um vote against him um during
the recent vote of no confidence i did
why didn't you leave then uh it's a very
good question i could quite happily have
done so um my
that's my instinct all the time and i
certainly support the government i
support what the government is trying uh
to do and i think it is a time for unity
for my party i don't think that unity is
going to be possible at the boris
johnson which is why i've come to the
conclusion that i have what do you want
the 1922 committee to do
well there are two ways of of moving
forward aren't there in the immediate
future more resignations ministerial
resignations i think might force the
issue that'd be the quickest way of
dealing with it if that doesn't work
then the back benches are going to have
to have another go
140 is a big number it wasn't enough but
i think a rule change is appropriate
indeed i think we're obliged to consider
a rule change okay
not at the moment because that isn't
going to happen unless they change the
rules for the rule change and that's
what that's what boris johnson has been
criticized for many times in the past
changing the rules when it doesn't suit
him
look this is the the 1922 rules are are
uh in a of a different order um we have
to have a mechanism a safety mechanism
for dealing with a prime minister who is
clearly not
fit for purpose i think we have a duty
to change the rules because we can't
leave this until june next year
what can he do to convince you otherwise
he can't and i've made that very clear
in my letter to him and indeed he's made
it clear himself in that he said last
week he can't change he's not going to
change
do you not feel that you had a
responsibility as trade envoy to
continue on with the work that you were
doing holding the uk in a good light to
i think it was morocco
morocco is very important to me i've got
a long-standing relationship with
morocco and certainly um
my work there is not done i will
continue it by other other means you can
be sure of that but it wasn't a decision
i took lightly because being a trade
envoy is a fairly fairly junior position
but it was important to me and i really
wanted to keep it because i think we're
making progress there but sometimes in
politics you've got to take a stand i
think your integrity depends upon it
which is why i acted like this so tell
me about that process from when you um
first saw i'm not sure about this prime
minister to actually penning the letter
well as i said to you it's been a long
burn for me and it's accumulation of a
whole load of things it's simply it's
not particulate it's important that
partygate uh is and and
desperately awful though it was it
simply wasn't just that it's a whole
raft of issues around the prime
minister's character his relationship
think about your emotion how you were
feeling oh deeply gutted i mean really
gutted to do that i'm not a quitter i'm
an arch loyalist if you look at my
20-year record as a member of parliament
i've always been loyal and so this is
completely contrary to my character
which is why it's so difficult for me
um was it nazim sahari on the program
this morning the new chancellor saying
he's completely confident that the prime
minister has integrity um okay well i
think everybody's got to speak for
themselves i respect nadim very much
indeed i hope he's able to hold things
together i imagine his narrative will be
that he is there to try and hold things
together and i wish him luck in his new
appointment would it be a good prime
minister
i'm certainly not going to be drawn on
successes to boris johnson
i i believe that boris needs to go now
he needs to salvage what dignity he can
from this pro process uh now but he
needs to go nevertheless how does he
salvage dignity in your opinion he needs
to go now without dragging this out he
can't be dragged out of number 10
that'll look awful you know we're a
sophisticated country we're not a banana
republic we don't have people clinging
on when they've lost all support among
their colleagues in the country
in the past what's happened is people in
the position that boris now finds
himself in uh just uh stand at the
podium outside number 10 and say look uh
it's been a great honor to serve but my
time is up and i hope he does that those
are very strong words aren't they um you
must feel very very passionate about
what you're saying i don't do things
likely i certainly don't resign lightly
i feel strongly that the time has come
for boris johnson to go what would you
say to other ministers junior ministers
or or cabinet ministers
in a similar position to you
i would say to them uh it's for them to
make up their own minds on this matter
those of them who have
leadership aspirations need to be very
careful however because backbench
colleagues like me will be taking note
of how they position themselves and if
they remain in office they are
vicariously liable for the prime
minister so i'm afraid they're going to
be associated
with what he does and we cannot um
complain about kierstama
and point out to the public as we really
should be uh doing uh that he served all
those years under jeremy corbyn if at
the same time there are people who are
prepared to stay in office supporting
boris johnson what is the gossip in the
tea rooms over the last 24 hours
um well i'm certainly not going to
divulge conversations in the in the tea
rooms tea room in confidence as it were
but i think the mood in among my
colleagues in general
is fevered and a sense that
this is certainly the beginning of the
end this has a sense of inevitability
about it with any other leader in our
history it certainly would be curtains
but boris is a particular sort of
individual which is why this is dragging
out for so long so do you expect more
resignations i would be very surprised
if there are more resignations today
could be today could be later this week
okay and just a quick thought we had uh
siraj gayle on the program this morning
he says could limp on until the autumn
the prime minister your thoughts on that
well there are two scenarios one we have
a deluge of ministerial resignations and
the position simply becomes
unsustainable even for somebody of the
tenacity of boris johnson in which case
it'll be game over very soon uh or we
have to have another go at the 19
through the 1922 process in which case i
think roger is correct this is going to
be an autumn job